[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone i'm jerry CEO and
co-founder of touch up modern and i want
to talk to you guys about the decision
between profitability and growth this is
one of those things that's often a trade
off that startups have to make because
you know in a perfect world you can do
both but in reality if you could do both
you would never tell anyone about it and
so we wouldn't be talking about it so
just some facts about touch of modern on
the kind of on the bird's-eye view
founder in 2012 16 million revenue 16
million registered users and we launched
about 30 brands a day on our site
because really we're all about discovery
and when we'll be showing something new
every single day obviously this is a
great challenge to be kind of doing this
on a day to day basis and so we've grown
to about 130 in annual sales and we got
to a point where we had to decide
whether or not to keep on this venture
funded growth path or make the pivot to
profitability i'll talk to you about
some of the decision points that we had
to weigh in to make that decision so
some of the factors that are really
important are the amount of money you've
raised versus the annual revenue and
this is something that's often
overlooked by young entrepreneurs
because in Silicon Valley you go out
there and you want to raise as much
money as possible obviously that's good
to give you a cushion because you always
need more than you think
but the bad thing is when you raise too
much for the actual revenue that you're
generating it limits your options in
terms of what you can do next because
with raising money comes expectations
from investors of how much you need to
grow before the next round some of the
things to consider also the past
valuations again everyone wants to pump
their valuations super high because it
feels good but again limits your options
for your next round as well because
obviously the next one needs to be
multiples higher than that and then for
we were practically near ebay da
profitable as a company the way we've
run the company
we always kind of looked at it as
swimming with one hand close enough to
edge of the pool where even though we're
growing we always knew that if we needed
to become profitable we could obviously
there's still some unknown of where that
I could pull it off but we had a pretty
good idea that we could and also not our
investors burned by e-commerce failures
but in general a lot of folks in the
space had become kind of jaded by
ecommerce because of some of the other
exits that happen in the recent years
right gilt you know a lot of investors
lost money on that some made money
obviously and likewise the other
companies that are that are near it so
what are some of the risks between
deciding so what are some of the risk of
the consider when deciding between
profitability and growth right when you
decide to become profitable obviously
the company culture really changes you
start managing to a much smaller number
which is the money actually bring in
versus the the high-level number which
is just gmv revenue whatever it is for
you guys and then also you start
thinking about competitors who are
pouring millions of dollars into
acquiring possibly the same market that
you are if you're gonna decide to become
profitable you're not going to be
spending as much as they are and you
need to figure out what you're gonna do
about that
so for us we finally decided to shift
from growth to profitability this is
about some time mid last year and the
reason we were able to do that is
because we did really deep research and
an analysis about our most loyal
customers because for us and for a lot
of companies in Silicon Valley the
greatest cost is marketing and growth
right and so if you're gonna pull back
on that what are you gonna do to make up
that revenue and for us we found that we
had a really loyal user base that we can
actually nurture and grow to offset the
amount that we were pulling back so here
are some stats about what we found about
our users which is actually really
unique for an e-commerce company so for
this is and this chart shows anybody
who's ever visited touch of modern the
site or the app in 2012
and we found that 10% of those people
actually come back every single day
which is really like gaming level
economics for a our gaming level metrics
for an e-commerce site right and about
40% of that entire group as you come
back at least once a week which means
they pretty much see every single thing
that we put up at any given time and 80%
of anyone who's visiting 2017 not just
purchased by anyone who's ever visited
actually come back at least once a month
and no surprise people who come back
more often also more likely to purchase
so someone who comes back on a daily
basis is about 10 times more likely to
buy than somebody that only comes back
once every three weeks and this is a
little bit also about the category
preferences so this is important because
if we're gonna talk about how do we
serve our best customers we need to know
how they're actually different than some
of our less profitable customers and we
found is that the category preferences
are actually completely inverted from
someone who so someone who visits every
single day and purchases a lot it's
actually completely inverted from
someone who doesn't visit a fan maybe
purchases once a year or less and this
is really important for us because we
found that okay well we can't actually
cut any category because people that are
new actually want the things that our
most loyal customers are not that
interested in right and so if we just
cut the categories that are not as
popular with our most loyal customers we
lose a user acquisition channel for new
users right and so we couldn't really
cut that but what we could do is really
beef up on the things that the most
loyal customers want just give you an
idea of you know the scale the spectrum
about 80% of our revenue come from the
top 20% of customers and so when we did
this there was a little bit outdated
from the first time we put this together
but we're now 10 months
EBIT are profitable after having made
that shift and focusing more on on the
repeat customer
and a little bit less on user
acquisition and so what are some of the
key takeaways and how should you decide
about becoming profitable versus
sticking to growth and there is a few
things that you really need to factor in
decision-making the first one is
understanding the market and what is
actually more valuable at the given time
so your main responsibility as a CEO as
a founder is to produce the most
valuable company that you can possibly
produce right and depending on investor
sentiment depending on what competitors
are doing or whatever market forces
there are at any given point growth
could be valued more profitability could
be valued more and in the years prior to
this decision that we've made growth was
obviously you know in style you know the
other companies were growing like crazy
but then when they started suddenly
failing investors suddenly got smart and
said you know what maybe burning a ton
of money just to grow the top-line
revenue is not the is not the smartest
thing for this kind of company right
because ecommerce is not like a SAS
company it's not super high margin and
you can't just kind of make small tweaks
and and and right the ship if you needed
to become profitable so they started
looking at you know how how do you
actually become profitable right because
all these other companies that spent so
much to grow couldn't do it so that was
something that the factors in our
decision-making right
in general what my philosophy and
philosophy of our founders has always
been is that growth for any given
category comes in and out of style but
profitability is always cool so it's
also the harder thing to do another
decision you have to think about is do
you actually have the levers or do you
understand the levers that you can pull
to achieve that desired result right and
for some companies it's easier to become
profitable because you know you've been
close or you really understand the
metrics and what you can tweak to get
there or it's easier just to raise money
because I don't know you have the
connections
you have an existing investor base I can
introduce you to other investors who can
get it done right both of these carry
their own execution risks because if you
were a growth company and you decide to
become a profitable company and you
can't get there then you're neither
possible nor are you growing and that is
really the worst position to be in
obviously and you know if you bet your
chips on growing and raising and raising
money to grow and that doesn't happen we
also fall flat on your face and thirdly
and I think this is probably the one
that is least talked about in the valley
is that even though you're you're you
know aligned with your investors because
the equity and all that the way that you
think about risk is also different than
the way that your investors think about
risk and you should have a very honest
conversation with your board and with
your investors about that right and I
think you know oftentimes when you're
starting out you think oh this is great
I'm putting in my time the investors are
putting the money so the risk is really
more on them it's actually not because
you only have your given amount of time
the investors have a large portfolio
they have a lot of companies that
they're betting on right you're just one
of them so they're always gonna ask you
to shoot for the moon because if you
fail you know there's a bunch of other
companies that that might make it for
you if you fail that's your entire
livelihoods and that's all the years
that you spent on this company right and
so you're gonna be a little bit more
risk-averse when it comes down to making
that decision so you know talk to them
and figure out what's really the best
for both of you thank you
[Applause]
you